i think we'll be a better navy from
having open
honest conversations
about racism being recommended in
america's military
no need to be fought in america's
military is what needs to happen you can
see the left pushing this kind of crap
and it's insane
okay you have aoc doing the same thing
it's essentially tying juneteenth
to critical race theory says oh the
reason that people are denying
juneteenth is because they also deny
critical race theory what if i what if i
like the idea of celebrating the end of
slavery and also think critical race
theory is bunk
in part because we ended slavery here is
aoc being
her normal genius itself
whether it's trying to fight against
teaching
basic history around racism and the role
of racism
in u.s history to you know there's a
direct
through line from that to denying
juneteen
the day that wheat that is widely
recognized
and celebrated as the symbolic kind of
day that
to represent the end of slavery in the
united states you know
there's a direct through line between
that denial of our history and wanting
to understand the full scope of our
history
and celebrating the end a major end of
injustice
in the united states okay so what the
left is lying about the left is lying
what they're lying about is they are
tying
juneteenth to critical race there
they're saying they're one in the same
so you can't do one without the other
and the right some on the right say okay
well fine so we won't do either
and the answer is no two things can be
true at once juneteenth is good and
critical race theory is bad
that is very easy to do okay it also
happens to be the truth
and you know you fight you can see the
game the left is playing here and it's
really
a quite despicable game again taking
elements of american history that should
unify us like you know america ending
slavery and turning it into a point of
division
in order to suggest that all of
america's institutions are hierarchical
in nature and must be torn to the ground
and the fact is that i i will
acknowledge i i am amazed at the extent
of which critical race theory has taken
over our institutions
truly it's amazing perfect example so
this week there was a a questioning for
chief of naval operations admiral
michael gilday
the chief of naval operations had put
out a list
of recommended books to members of the
navy including iberomex kennedy's
garbage fascist tyrannical racist book
how to be anti-racist it is a piece of
crap that book it is a terrible terrible
book
again not calling for its suppression
because i believe in free speech
you should read the book and then you
should recognize how stupid it is okay
but
being recommended in america's military
a a book that basically argues that
america is inevitably and inherently
racist
and evil and that active discriminatory
measures must be taken today
okay so admiral gilray or gilday rather
was questioned by republican study
committee chairman jim banks and he
defended all this he said no it's very
good
we need critical race theory needs to be
taught to the members of america's
military
that needs to be fought in america's
military is what needs to happen
admiral why did you put this book on the
reading list and recommend it to
that every single united states sailor
read it because i think it's really
important to consider
a variety of views you said you read
this book what part of this book is
redeeming
and and qualifies as something that that
every
every sailor is critical about his own
journey
as an african-american in this country
what he's experienced
let me ask you again admiral do you
expect
that say after sailors read this book
that says that the united states navy is
racist
that we will increase or decrease morale
cohesion and recruiting race into the
united states navy
i think we'll be a better navy from
having open honest
conversations about racism
it's not an open honest conversation
about racism and this is the lie that
people
who have now wormed their way into the
heights of all of america's institutions
continue to promulgate this stuff this
is why and by the way it's just honestly
it's an avoidance technique
for so many members of the left who
don't want to govern and be good at
their jobs it's an avoidance technique
you suck at your job and so you blame
racism and talk about how
racism is the big specter out there
lurking that is causing you to suck at
your job this is what mario lori
lightfoot is doing mayor lori light for
the garbage mayor of chicago
shootings have been out of control under
lori lightfoot she's allowed people to
just ransack chicago's loop she's awful
in every respect
but there is a public health crisis she
says the public health crisis in chicago
wade for away it
racism almost every single point in our
city's history
sadly racism has taken a devastating
toll
on the health and well-being of our
residents of color
and particularly those who are black
without formally acknowledging this
history and reality
and the continuing impact of that
infamous legacy
looking at the root causes of today's
challenges
we will never be able to move forward as
a city and fully provide
our communities with the resources that
we need
to live happy vibrant and fulfilled
lives
that's why ladies and gentlemen i am
here today
with racial equity and healthcare
leaders to formally
declare systemic racism as a public
health
crisis here in chicago
okay all that is a way to avoid
governing that's all it is
okay so again celebrate the country by
celebrating the good
that it does and recognize that the left
will always attempt to use everything as
a club to beat you into submission
and and that's what left is doing day
it's why the left can't just take the
win
it's not even a win for them it's why
the left can't just accept the
unification of juneteenth and instead
tries to turn it immediately
into a divisive issue about the
continuing evils of the united states
which by the way is a message
directly contrary to the message of
actually juneteenth
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment